the Joe Rogan experience Madagascar was
it a little a little bit different
Madagascar was a beautiful country but
down south it's very polished people
suffered with malnutrition malaria's big
out there because kill I caught malaria
almost died from it
you can't malaria caught malaria yeah so
you weren't on malaria medication yeah I
was on malaria medication I came across
a community that had the suffering with
bubonic plague such an ancient disease
and they pretty much said I had two
guides with me at this time so they were
able to translate the pretty much said
stay in your tent you know we've had
relatives die we've got the suffering
with the plague here that instantly made
me feel a nervy on edge you know there's
rats and dogs running around you go away
go away zipped in so they would do the
cooking and they bought me this eel
smell a little bit funky but we were
hungry me and my two guides we eat the
ER for the next few days we were
suffering with diarrhea and I believed
that the anti malarial pills they only
cover you up to 80% anyway it was going
in one way out of the other and I didn't
have to for 80% protecting me from the
strain of malaria I caught malaria and I
it threw me back to the Gobi Desert so
the symptoms and signs I was suffering
with felt like I was just suffering with
dehydration I was I was getting weak and
weak I was losing a lot of weight that
was vomiting and it got to a point where
days went by that I was like this isn't
dehydration this is this is a disease
I'm suffering with something but I
pushed on made it to a community that I
knew had Overland transport how far did
you walk with malaria I think I probably
walked four days or so with malaria holy
[ __ ] yeah it was brutal oh but at that
time I had no idea right so I'm like I'm
dehydrated so I should drink and drink
and think I'm gonna get better soon made
it to the community arrived at one of
the nearest hospitals and she said you
potentially made inside potentially a
few hours before you slipped into a coma
and that's when I realize it was the
deadliest strain of malarious fall suit
poram so you got four different strains
of malaria got the deadliest and it
usually kills you within 24 hours
but I believe I lasted five days because
I was taking the anti-malarials and then
that one you can eradicate fully out of
your system
now when you're on the anti-malaria
medication and you're [ __ ] yourself
so it doesn't stay in your system are
you taking more of it when you think you
have it I know I wasn't asked at set as
well overdose because you can't you know
you can't you don't know how much you
don't know how much is still in your
system how much are you allowed to take
of it
I want one pill a day it was C breath
which Justin Wren was saying that he
experienced toxicity because he was
taking five pills a day
remember when Justin was talking about
that he's yeah we actually researched
that there's been problems with some
troops that get on that anti-malaria
medication and they get really sick from
it yeah it actually doesn't it do
something to your brain yeah
remember that's the mother on that yes
that's like a strong dose isn't it
what's tougher you want what I was on
doxycycline does I think tomorrow the
mark Maret oh how do I say honey said
Merritt Maryland from our own covers you
about 100% I think my dad was on that
and I said Affleck win methyl so that's
a different that's right so was stronger
no but he was on it and he's gotten it
Justin he runs a charity called fight
for the forgotten the old wells for the
pygmies he's dying three times yeah and
what strain it was yeah that was it yeah
yeah I remember him talking about it
because the three lowest rate in ski can
actually remain dormant in your system
that's what they said with him he got it
again after he had it malaria drug
causes brain damage that mimics PTSD
[ __ ] a malaria drug the drug the drug
us insane not even just hilarious yeah
so I became I pointed up with malaria no
more UK after that because and one side
contracted it I was the look you want to
survive and then as I pushed on still
had four months to go I got in month one
of a five-month journey to walk do
servant from to walk south to north of
Madagascar so it said eight highest
mountains along the way so it took 155
days this journey did and it was 1,600
miles slightly bigger than the Mongolia
and a lot of it was just machete in hand
hacking through the jungle
leeches dropping down spider bites
hunting gathering your hunting and
gathering out there - yeah in the jungle
yeah you know where you can gather the
local so I have no military background
that's all doing this which is usually
strangest normally a military background
to come in to do the survival but
everything that I've learned I've tried
to get as much knowledge as I possibly
can from the locals
so like the mind the mind more Hill
community Mongolia how they survive
Madagascar what's edible what isn't
edible how to build raft etc so on I
always try to take a small percent and
that's where you can ever take us that's
so knowledgeable as to what they can eat
what they can gather what they can't you
know it's a lifetime isn't it so I just
had to try to pick up as much as I could
in a short space of time but again I was
learning as we went we were yeah doing
some hunting doing some gathering but we
were losing weight yeah at all there was
three or four weeks of jungle territory
further up north of the island we had a
photographer join us for that one and it
got to a point where they just hated it
I did too it was the cyclone season we
were covering we were walking about 14
hours a day and we would cover maybe
three miles if were just hacking through
his sheer dense jungle and down
mountains one day we had to turn around
and do you turn and walk three days back
on myself it's a fun different way up
the mountain puts into perspective no
when you do a you tune in a car right
it's just to you too
[Applause]